It's the perfect time of year to hunker down
inside for a movie night or dedicate a weekend
to binge-watching a new series.
There's no need to head out to the theater
here are a few Netflix originals you've probably
missed so far.
Proving that 2019 is the year Netflix goes
totally international, Justice tells the story
of Farah, a young woman from the United Arab
Emirates who studied law in the United States,
and returns to her home city of Abu Dhabi
in order to practice.
Her father is one of the top attorneys in
the UAE, and he's pleased to see Farah follow
in his footsteps, but there's a catch Farah
wants to work for herself and open her own
practice, but her father wants her to work
at his firm.
In order to prove herself, Farah begins taking
on intriguing pro bono cases, which are based
on real cases that have gone through Abu Dhabi's
justice system.
With true-to-life characters who are caught
between tradition and modernity, Justice gives
viewers a peek into family life in the UAE,
and the series is as educational as it is
entertaining.
Fatima Al Taei's portrayal of Farah is sympathetic
and relatable, and she makes the character's
ambitious nature shine through in every scene.
When a series kicks off with a theme song
written by the legendary Leonard Cohen, expectations
are going to be high, and from the intro sequence
to the end credits, Black Earth Rising does
not disappoint.
Protagonist Kate Ashby is rescued from the
aftermath of the Rwandan genocide as a child
by her adoptive mother, Eve, who works as
a successful international human rights lawyer.
Kate eventually grows up to work side by side
with Eve as a legal investigator.
When Eve prosecutes a militia leader who stood
up against genocide in the Democratic Republic
of Congo and but now finds himself accused
of crimes against humanity, Kate and Eve have
to grapple with difficult questions surrounding
good, evil, the complexity of morality and
where they stand in their relationship with
each other.
"I don't remember my family.
Or my country.
Nothing.
I don’t know my own name!"
Black Earth Rising comes with some familiar
star power in the form of John Goodman as
Kate's employer, but it's not the kind of
series you can zone out on.
Each episode pushes viewers to think critically
and refuses to spoon-feed answers to the issues
it presents.
In the world of Black Earth Rising, nothing
is really black or white, and everything exists
in shades of gray.
The Icelandic film And Breathe Normally premiered
at the Sundance Film Festival in January 2018
to overwhelmingly positive critical reception.
Now, it's available for Netflix audiences
everywhere.
Lara is a struggling single mother living
near Reykjavik who forms an unlikely bond
with Adja, a refugee seeking asylum who is
about to be deported.
Lara is nothing if not stubborn, and she seems
like the last person to accept help from a
stranger.
On the other hand, Adja has almost nothing
to give but somehow, she offers Lara what
little she can to support her, and Lara allows
herself to be vulnerable and let Adja into
her world.
And Breathe Normally touches on several topics
that dominate today's headlines, from Lara's
attempts to disguise poverty as an adventure
for her son to scenes in the refugee center
where Adja lives in limbo.
"Do you know how long I have to stay here?"
"No, I don’t know.
It’s just a system."
This is not the side of Iceland that you see
in tourism ad campaigns — the cold, rocky
landscape is the backdrop for a nuanced look
at this seemingly utopian nation.
Combine the exciting fight scenes of a martial
arts film with the tension of a drama series,
throw in some supernatural elements, and you've
got Wu Assassins.
Kai Jin, a chef working in San Francisco's
Chinatown, learns his true identity: he's
actually the last of the Wu Assassins, a line
of warriors tasked with using their powers
to kill the Wu Warlords.
The Warlords also possess magical abilities
connected to fire, earth, water, wood, and
metal.
San Francisco is now under threat from the
warlords, and despite Kai's protests that
he's just a chef, he has no choice but to
step up, embrace his new role, and fight against
them.
The high points of Wu Assassins are definitely
the tightly choreographed fight scenes this
is star Iko Uwais' first TV series, but his
previous work as a fight and action choreographer
on films like The Raid definitely prepared
him for this role.
The show has received some criticism for lackluster
writing and pacing issues and a few rough
special effects, but if it's renewed for a
second season, the cast and crew has already
created an imaginative world of interesting
characters on which to build a strong sophomore
effort.
The follow up to Medici: Masters of Florence,
Medici: The Magnificent takes place 20 years
after the events of the first season, and
introduces several new cast members, including
Sean Bean, of Game of Thrones fame, and Alessandra
Mastronardi, who you might've seen on Netflix's
own Master of None.
Set in 15th century Florence, Medici: The
Magnificent continues to focus on the lives
of Florence's most influential family, the
Medici.
After Piero de Medici is killed, his son Lorenzo
has to take control of their family-run bank.
Nicknamed "Lorenzo the Magnificent," he decides
to change the way his family does business,
which stirs up trouble with Florence's other
powerful banking clan, the Pazzi.
Now, Jacopo Pazzi is dead set on bringing
Lorenzo down.
"a change to may bring a change to Florence.
And with Piero recording roads there may be
better ways of destroying the Medici than
with a blade."
Fans will be happy to see this series return
with fresh faces and an engaging new plot.
Medici: The Magnificent was certainly written
for maximum drama over historical accuracy,
but who wouldn't want to dive into centuries-old
conspiracy theories about Florentine high
society for a few hours?
Soni has already been labeled the best Hindi
Netflix original so far, which is certainly
an impressive accolade.
Headstrong protagonist Soni is a policewoman
in Delhi, a city where the justice system
rarely gives women the benefit of the doubt.
Alongside her superintendent Kalpana, the
two have taken it upon themselves to investigate
violent crimes against women.
The women balance each other out Soni is bold
and hotheaded, while Kalpana always manages
to remain calm.
But when Soni is transferred out of their
department after facing allegations of misconduct,
their partnership takes a hit.
Rather than veering into buddy cop tropes,
Soni is an unapologetically feminist film
with a thoughtful and honest depiction of
the issues that women in India face.
Between their very different roles at work
and at home, Soni and Kalpana seem to live
double lives, a predicament that will be relatable
to audiences around the world.
The Spanish horror film Ánimas is getting
mixed reviews, but if you happen to be staying
in on a dark and stormy night, it's the perfect
movie to fit the mood.
Written and directed by Laura Alvea, the plot
of Ánimas is centered around Abraham and
Álex, friends who struggle to maintain their
close bond when Abraham begins dating his
new girlfriend Anchi.
Somehow, Anchi's arrival into Abraham's life
kicks off a series of increasingly strange
and frightening events, from the death of
Abraham's abusive father to Álex's unsettling
and unexplainable visions.
Ánimas falls squarely into the category of
atmospheric horror the flickering lighting
combined with the appropriately garish color
palette makes every scene feel a little bit
like a bad trip.
There's a pervasive sense of isolation that
separates Álex and Abraham from the rest
of the world, and it always seems like they're
trapped, with no one coming to save them from
themselves.
A series that starts off by introducing a
recently widowed protagonist who lost her
husband in a car accident sounds like it would
lean heavier on tragedy than comedy, but Dead
to Me consistently dabbles in black humor
in its depiction of grief.
"Just can't imagine what you’re going through."
"Well it’d be like if Jeff got hit by a
car and died suddenly and violently.
Like that."
Christina Applegate stars as Jen, a young
widow is mourning the loss of her husband,
who meets Judy, played by Linda Cardellini,
at a support group, sparking an unlikely friendship.
But Judy's unwavering support and carefree
attitude might not be the saving grace that
Jen was hoping for.
When Jen invites Judy to live in her guesthouse,
she quickly finds out that Judy tends to leave
trouble in her wake, and her past is finally
catching up to her.
Dead to Me could have gone for mainstream
drama, but the raw, realistic portrayal of
female friendship and appropriately dark quips
and one liners are what make it so binge-worthy.
It dodges tired tropes at every turn and keeps
you hooked right through the finale.
With acclaimed filmmaker Ava DuVernay serving
as the co-creator, writer, and director of
When They See Us, it's clear that the series
is a must-watch, and there's a good chance
that it will turn your worldview on its head
before the credits roll.
DuVernay is known for her films exploring
racism and the history of civil rights in
the United States, like Selma and 13th, and
her skill at clearly illustrating how these
issues still affect our society today.
She continues down that path with this series,
which is based on a 1989 case often referred
to as the "Central Park Five."
When a female jogger was attacked while out
running through Central Park, five young men
between the ages of 14 and 16, four black
and one Hispanic, were convicted of the crime
despite a lack of hard evidence.
All of them served prison time, but in 2002,
their convictions were finally overturned
when DNA evidence confirmed the validity of
another man's confession.
DuVernay actually refused to use the "Central
Park Five" moniker in the series, stating
she wanted the men to be seen as individuals.
This dramatic exposé of the criminal justice
system is impossible to look away from.
Hindi-language films and series are having
a moment on Netflix, proving that there's
more to India's film industry than Bollywood
musicals.
The series Typewriter is set in Goa, a region
of India known by travelers for its popular
beaches and quaint fishing villages but when
three aspiring young ghost hunters decide
to explore a supposedly haunted villa, they
have to confront the dark forces at work in
their neighborhood.
When a new family moves into the villa, the
terrifying legends whispered about the house
come to life.
Curiously enough, the haunting itself seems
to be connected to an old typewriter and trying
to remove it from the house proves to be a
dangerous mistake.
The young protagonists setting out to solve
a supernatural mystery welcomes comparisons
to Stranger Things, but Typewriter isn't just
filler to hold you over until Netflix takes
you back to Hawkins.
The series stands on its own, and it's legitimately
frightening.
The overarching plot isn't particularly unique
in the horror genre, but it's undeniably binge-worthy.
With only five episodes, you might be tempted
to watch it all in one night.
Be warned: you'll probably want to sleep with
the lights on.
They say that a dog is a man's best friend,
and the Spanish comedic drama Seventeen proves
that there's no bond like the one between
a boy and his pup.
Hector, a troubled teen who couldn't keep
himself from getting dragged in front of a
judge, has spent the past two years living
in a youth detention center, and he's dedicated
most of that time to trying to figure out
how to escape.
After training a therapy dog, Sheep, as part
of a program with the local shelter, he finally
begins feeling content but when Sheep is adopted
by a new owner, Hector decides he's had enough.
Hector breaks out of the center and gets in
touch with his brother and grandmother, enlisting
their help to track down Sheep.
Sure, they'll have to commit a few crimes
and misdemeanors along the way, which has
never bothered Hector in the past.
Now, though, there's only one catch he has
two days before he turns 18 and can be tried
as an adult.
In 1988, police officer Thomas Lockhart's
obsession with tracking down an elusive serial
killer takes hold.
Several victims in Philadelphia have bled
to death from similar wounds, and Lockhart
becomes convinced that if he can just crack
this difficult case, he'll finally get to
become a detective.
But the mysterious suspect continues to thwart
him for years on end, leaving him with nothing
but inexplicable clues and dead ends.
Nine years later, Lockhart has moved forward
in his career and become a detective.
A copycat killer strikes, and as Lockhart
tries to connect the dots, he realizes that
the details just aren't adding up.
This is not just a serial killer at work there's
something bigger at play here.
When Lockhart encounters his prime suspect
from 1988 and sees that she hasn't aged a
day, he dedicates his life to figuring out
her identity, her motives, and whether or
not she's from an entirely different time
and place.
"The more I tell the more the more you’ll
keep coming after me.
And I’ve seen how that turns out for you."
In the Shadow of the Moon is a refreshing
take on the typical police procedural, and
the supernatural elements keep it from feeling
like a carbon copy of similar narratives in
the genre.
The surprising conclusion explores complex
moral issues and examines the true meaning
of justice.
If you're a huge Marvel fan and you just can't
get enough of seeing superhero stories come
to life on screen, the charming and occasionally
nail-biting series Raising Dion might be right
up your alley.
Most popular superhero films follow well-known
comic book characters in their adult years,
but what were these larger-than-life figures
like as children?
"Okay can we not set anything on fire?"
In Raising Dion, widowed single mother Nicole
is taking care of her son Dion on her own
after the death of her husband.
And as if the overwhelming responsibilities
of being a single mother weren't enough, Dion
begins exhibiting magical abilities he doesn't
quite understand it, but he's a superhero
in the making.
Unfortunately, it's not all fun and games
for Dion.
Powerful forces are out to exploit him for
their own ambitions, and now, Nicole must
enlist help to protect him.
Plus, she needs to figure out how he developed
his powers in the first place and what his
future might hold.
Beats is the latest feature offering from
director Chris Robinson, who made his feature
film debut with the drama ATL in 2005.
Robinson is best known for his work directing
music videos for artists like Alicia Keys,
Eminem, and Nicki Minaj, and his knowledge
of the business clearly informs the plot of
Beats.
Bonus: the soundtrack is packed with songs
by up-and-coming hip hop artists.
August is an introverted teenager who is reeling
after the loss of his sister.
While he shuts himself away in his room and
shirks his responsibilities, he throws himself
into his only creative outlet: music.
When school security guard Romelo drops by
his house to speak to August's mother about
his absence, he overhears the beats August
has been working on and is immediately intrigued
by his surprising talent.
"Ro" has a surprise of his own up his sleeve:
he's also a music manager, and now, he wants
to take August under his wing.
But August's heavy grief and insecurities
threaten to weigh him down as he tries to
rise to the occasion.
"You get that?
I’m not good.
Everywhere I go I see it."
The story of a young underdog trying to break
into a tough industry with guidance from an
unexpected mentor isn't a particularly original
concept in itself, but the characters in Beats
are the real highlight.
August is sensitive and conflicted, eager
to strive for more yet fragile in the wake
of his sister's death.
Supporting characters, like August's protective
mother Carla, played by Orange is the New
Black's Uzo Aduba, round out a solid cast.
From the very first episode of The Chosen
One, you know that the outlook isn't promising
for the main characters.
After all, messing with villagers who would
rather be left alone has been the downfall
of protagonists throughout film history.
A group of doctors is sent deep into the Brazilian
wetlands to vaccinate the residents of an
isolated village against Zika virus, but despite
the good intentions of Lucia, Damiao, and
Enzo, it's clear that they're not going to
be welcomed with open arms.
The villagers aren't just hostile because
they don't want to be bothered by outsiders.
They outright refuse to be vaccinated, insisting
that polluting their bodies with modern medicine
will cause them to lose the protection of
"The Chosen One," their local religious figure.
The doctors must grapple with burning questions
of science and faith to dig up the secrets
at the heart of this village and determine
if something beyond their rational understanding
is really at play.
The acting in The Chosen One might feel a
bit more reminiscent of a soap opera than
prestige TV, but that doesn't detract much
from the entertainment value.
And with only six addictive episodes in its
first season, it's easy to race through this
series in a few hours.
The Last Czars is that kind of rare show that's
both entertaining and educational.
This visually appealing historical drama series
switches between fictional reenactments and
documentary-style commentary to provide further
context, which makes for an interesting format
reminiscent of a History Channel program.
It might not resonate with those who would
prefer to simply lose themselves in the story,
but you'll appreciate the extra background
info if you're the type who often finds yourself
googling questions while watching period pieces.
If your knowledge of Russian history starts
and ends with the animated film Anastasia,
The Last Czars might help fill in a few of
the gaps.
The series follows the life of Czar Nicholas
II, his resistance to political change, the
ensuing revolution, and the fall of the Romanov
dynasty.
If you can let a few historical inaccuracies
in the background slide, the royal scandals,
intricate costumes, and intriguing portrayals
of the Romanov family will more than make
up for it.
The names may sound familiar, but the series
brings these historical figures to life in
a way that explores their humanity.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.